a set of middle school students heights
are normally distributed with a mean of
150 centimeters and a standard deviation
of 20 centimeters darnell is a middle
school student with a height of 161
point four centimeters what proportion
of student heights are lower than
Darnell's height so let's think about
what they are asking so they're saying
that heights are normally distributed so
it would have a shape that looks
something like that that's my hand-drawn
version of it there's a mean of 150
centimeters so right over here that
would be 150 centimeters they tell us
that there's a standard deviation of 20
centimeters and Darnell has the height
of 161 point 4 centimeters so Darnell is
above the mean so let's say he is right
over here
and I'm not drawing it exactly but you
get the idea that is 161 point 4
centimeters and we want to figure out
what proportion of students Heights are
lower than Darnell's height so we want
to figure out what is the area under the
normal curve right over here that will
give us the proportion that are lower
than Darnell's height and I'll give you
a hint on how to do this we need to
think about how many standard deviations
above the mean is Darnell and we can do
that because they tell us what the
standard deviation is and we know the
difference between Darnell's height and
the mean height and then once we know
how many standard deviations he is above
the mean that's our z-score we can look
at a Z table that tell us what
proportion is less than that amount in a
normal distribution so let's do that so
I have my ti-84 emulator right over here
and let's see Darnell is 161 point four
centimeters 161 point four now the mean
is 150 - 150 is equal to we could have
done that in our head eleven point four
centimeters
now how many standard deviations is that
above the mean well they tell us that a
standard deviation in this case for this
distribution is 20 centimeters so we'll
take 11 point 4 divided by 20 so we will
just take our previous answer so this
just means our previous answer divided
by 20 centimeters and that gets us zero
point five seven so we can say that this
is zero point five seven standard
deviations deviations above the mean now
why is that useful well you could take
this z-score right over here and look at
a Z table to figure out what proportion
is less than zero point five seven
standard deviations above the mean so
let's get a Z table over here so what
we're going to do is we're going to look
up this z-score on this table and the
way that you do it this first column
each row tells us our z-score up until
the tenths place and then each of these
columns after that tell us which
hundreds were in so zero point five
seven the tenths place is right over
here so we're going to be in this row
and then our hundredths place is this
seven so we'll look right over here so
zero point five seven this tells us the
proportion that is lower than zero point
five seven standard deviations above the
mean and so it is zero point seven one
five seven or another way to think about
it is if the heights are truly normally
distributed seventy one point five seven
percent of the students would have a
height less than Darnell's but the
answer to this question what proportion
of students Heights are lower than
Darnell's height well that would be zero
point seven one five seven and they want
our answer to four decimal places which
is exactly what we have done